le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui doit donc s'exprimer dit
fier quelques instants depuis la place
beauvau son ministère de l'intérieur
doit très certainement prendre des
annonces concernant les mesures de
confinement avant de retourner du côté
de la place beauvau et d'écouté et
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur un mot sur les forces de
l'ordre qui menacent d'exercer leur
droit de retrait face à la crise
sanitaire les syndicats de police
s'alarme du manque de moyens de
protection
ils ont demandé hier justement un
christophe castaner d'autoriser le port
des masques aux agents et d'équiper tous
les services de moyens de protection
indispensable eux estiment que les
moyens de protection ne sont pas
suffisants un collectif de personnel de
santé accuse le premier ministre et l'ex
ministre de la santé de négligence
coupable dans la gestion de la crise lié
aux copies de 19
hier ce collectif nous met ces 19 a
annoncé par le biais d'un communiqué de
presse rédigé par son cabinet d'avocats
la saisine de la cour de justice de la
république d'une plainte pénale à
l'encontre des doors philippe et d'agnès
busin fabrice di vizio est avocat
spécialiste des médecins libéraux il dit
ne pas faire confiance au gouvernement
dans la gestion de la crise dédié aux
copies de 19,7 ont absolument plus à
rien sinon au pire vous avez affaire à
un gouvernement de menteur qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire enfin pardonnez moi
mais à un moment donné il faut être
honnête et de retour du côté de la place
beauvau priorité au direct sauf castaner
s'exprime d'aucune ministère de
l'intérieur et de nos concitoyens pour
soi même pour nos proches pour celles et
ceux qui nous soignent elle implique le
respect des règles elle implique de la
discipline elle implique des
comportements citoyens citoyen est
exemplaire
ce matin le président de la république
le premier ministre ont présidé ensemble
ici à l'hôtel de beauvau au siège du
ministère à l'intérieur une cellule
interministérielle de crise pour faire
le point sur le respect des consignes
que nous avons mises en place je
voudrais réinsisté une nouvelle fois je
le ferai sans cesse
la meilleure façon de combattre le coc
vite 19 c'est de rester chez soi c'est
de ne pas chercher à exploiter à
utiliser les différentes dérogation
exceptionnelle qui sont prévues sur les
déplacements
j'invite chacune et chacun à appliquer
une règle simple se rendre de son
domicile sur son lieu de travail puis
après on a fait quelques courses rentrer
chez soi rester chez soi il est
essentiel que ces règles soient
respectées
ce que nous constatons c'est que les
dérogations nécessaires utiles pour la
vie des français sont exploités détourné
par quelques-uns et qu'au moment où je
vous parle chacun en tête ce qui même en
faisant une déclaration cherche à ruser
cherche au fond à faire les malins pour
se croire des héros parce qu'ils
auraient détourné la règle
je voudrais que les choses soient
claires il ne s'agit pas pour nous de
sanctionner mais il s'agit de protéger
protéger aussi ceux qui ont ces
comportement anormal et donc s'il n'a
pas été question ce matin de durcir les
mesures qui sont mises en oeuvre parce
que nous les savons difficile
il a été décidé que leur mise en oeuvre
serait appliquée de façon plus stricte
encore ainsi par exemple dans les gares
pour le départ au week-end il sera
rappelé et seront sanctionnés tous les
comportements parce que il n'ya pas de
dérogation pour partir en week-end
le combat que nous menons implique
justement d'éviter de se déplacer
implique justement s'ils ont infecté et
qu'on ne le sait pas de déplacer le
virus un peu partout en france
nous avons donné des instructions très
claires pour que des contrôles soient
faits dans toutes les gares dont tous
les aéroports
et pour que les déplacements qui sont
possibles le soin que dans le cadre des
autorisations nécessaires pas dans le
cadre des loisirs de la même façon nous
sommes vendredi le week-end approche il
fera certainement beau un peu partout en
france et il ne s'agit pas de se
retrouver sur une plage sur une place
publique de se retrouver sur les berges
de la seine je voudrais saluer salué
l'engagement des maires des
collectivités locales qui ont pris les
décisions courageuses en lien avec les
préfets
d'interdire par exemple à paris les
voies sur berge ou à nice la promenade
des anglais
j'invite les maires à utiliser la
totalité de leur pouvoir de police pour
veiller à ce que tous ces lieux de
promiscuité qui sont autant de lieux de
diffusion du mal du coc vite 19 soit
interdite et nous ferons appliquer cela
avec la plus grande rigueur
je voudrais saluer ces initiatives qui
sont nés localement et qui sont nés de
l'intelligence locale bien sûr il ne
s'agit pas d'établir un couvre-feu
national sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais il s'agit d'accompagner initiatives
locales comme celle du maire de nice qui
prévoit un couvre-feu partiel sur
l'ensemble de sa commune parce que avec
le préfet avec les acteurs locaux
il a le sentiment que c'est la meilleure
façon de protéger sa population
je voudrais leur dire nous sommes
totalement engagés les cent mille
policiers et gendarmes sont engagées sur
le terrain pour protéger dans quelques
heures une modification l'initiative
permettra aussi aux polices municipales
là encore en lien avec les mairies de
faire en sorte que les infractions aux
déplacements puisse être supprimés
mesdames et messieurs il en va de la vie
de personne que l'on aime
il en va de sa propre protection il en
va de la protection de nos familles de
nos enfants il est donc essentiel de
respecter ces règles
elles sont simples je sais qu'elles sont
contraignantes mais elles sont simples
et elles servent la vie elle sauvé la
vie de ceux que l'on aime et donc elles
impliquent cet effort là nous devons
rien relâcher et les forces de sécurité
intérieure ne relâcheront rien et j'ai
demandé que des efforts soient portées
ce week-end pour que les plages auquel
on a l'habitude de se rendre et sur
lesquels on aime flâner ne soit pas ce
lieu-là pendant ce week-end j'avais
chacune et chacun a bien respecté ce qui
fait le vivre ensemble notre citoyenneté
et qui garantit la protection de chacune
et chacun
c'est un combat que nous menons il
implique des règles strictes mais simple
ne cherchons pas les détourner sinon
nous sanctionnerons
[Musique]
vous avez question de la crise
syndicale des internes de médecine
physique on s'était plaint c'est par
moment à lyon
vous savez de l'intersyndicale des
internes en médecine sont des voix
fortes que nous entendons toutes les
décisions que le gouvernement et le
président de la république ont pris
depuis le début de la gestion des crises
se construisent à partir justement de ce
regard scientifique et c'est sur la base
de ce regard scientifique que nous
devons mettre en oeuvre les mesures qui
sont mises en place et en même temps il
ne s'agit pas d'arrêter le pays ne
s'agit pas d'empêcher les gens d'aller
travailler d'empêcher les gens de faire
leurs courses et donc il faut trouver ce
point d équilibre là si les mesures doit
être prolongée si les mesures doivent
être durcies et si l'éclairage
scientifique est nécessaire évidemment
la décision politique sera au rendez
vous non le conseil de défense et de
sécurité qui s'est réuni ce matin n'a
pas acté la prolongation nous allons
analyser nous le faisons chaque jour à
chaque instant la situation dans les
hôpitaux sous l'autorité du ministre de
la santé et des solidarités olivier vos
rangs du directeur général de la santé
sous le regard du conseil scientifique
qui nous accompagne aussi nous devons
évaluer et l'édition seront prises mais
vous avez bien noté la détermination la
détermination du président de la
réplique à protéger les français et nous
protégeons les français même quand cela
se traduit par des contraintes des
difficultés mais il est essentiel que
nous nous d'action ensemble face à ces
contraintes pour préserver la vie
[Musique]
la totale application des mesures le
combat contre tous les détournements le
combat contre tous ces imbéciles qui
pensent qu'il serait des héros des héros
si au fond ils ne sont que des gens qui
met tant que ce qui met en danger la vie
d'autrui et donc oui il y a une très
très grande majorité de français qui
sont mobilisés et qui respecte les
règles
il y à une minorité qui cherche à les
détourner il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
pris conscience de la réalité du combat
que nous devons mener alors nous allons
veiller à ce que toutes les mesures
soient appliquées correctement pour
sauver des vies
ça se vend des procédures judiciaires
qui seront engagés mais il ne considère
pas que quelqu'un qui se promène dans la
rue met en danger la vie d'autrui
mais il ya des comportements qui sont
inacceptables depuis 48 heures nous
procédons 72 heures maintenant ou nous
procédons à des contrôles les forces de
sécurité intérieure font objet de très
nombreux outrages de très nombreuses
agressions et là encore nous devons
protéger nos forces de sécurité je dois
mon salut est aussi cet engagement
exceptionnel de ce qui fait notre
service public
je pense bien sûr aux blouses blanches
aux hôpitaux à tout le système sanitaire
mais je pense aussi aux policiers aux
gendarmes qui se sont instantanément
organisé pour accompagner les français
dans ces mesures de protection et pour
mettre en place les contrôles près de
550 milles contrôles ont été réalisés
dans les 48 premières heures de la mise
en oeuvre des décisions du président de
la république nous allons organiser leur
temps de travail pour qu'il puisse aussi
se reposer c'est nécessaire nous
travaillons avec eux sur la meilleure
façon justement d'organiser ces
contrôles et donc c'est avec toutes les
forces de sécurité intérieure que nous
devons être présents nous le serons ce
week-end sur les lieux plus touristique
que nous l'avons été sur les lieux de
transport par exemple cette semaine mais
nous adapterons notre dispositif tant
que c'est nécessaire il ya chez nos
forces de sécurité intérieure de
l'inquiétude
comme chez tous les français mais il ya
aussi de la détermination et du courage
que je voudrais saluer merci beaucoup
voilà donc l'intervention brève du
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner environ cinq minutes de prise
de parole suivi de quelques minutes de
questions réponses avec les journalistes
christophe castaner qui exhorte donc au
respect des règles à la discipline
un tour de vis du ministre de
l'intérieur qui dénonce des
comportements qui permettent de
détourner les dérogations pas de
couvre-feu national selon christophe
castaner sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais il incite au couvre-feu partiel
comme c'est le cas à nice avec un couvre
feu
dès ce soir il a également salué les
décisions locales comme à paris le fait
de fermer ce week end les voies sur
berge le champs de mars ou encore les
invalides et à nice la promenade des
anglais
c'est la fin de cette édition on se
retrouve ici quelques instants nouveau
jt rester sur les radios
et
[Musique]
il y aura probablement deux attitudes
une fois un soft votre site soit un
arbre existe si sarah ben brik si comme
vous dites bien les clubs tels que
arsenal manchester liverpool et consorts
ne pourront plus acheter des joueurs qui
n'ont pas été internationaux mais ça
peut devenir très technique parce que
l'angleterre le royaume uni peut aussi
changer sa fiscalité pour vendre des
plats les plus attractifs aux étrangers
il focalise beaucoup plus sur les
résultats magnifiques et elle est
beaucoup